buenos días pues emanuel makoun ha
querido desde 2017 cuando llegó a la
poder aquí en la francia reanudar y
renovar las relaciones del país con el
continente africano y en particular con
esas antiguas colonias en 2017 por quina
faso él dio un discurso que hay sentó un
precedente porque él habló de esa
restitución de bienes culturales a
varios países y la necesidad de que los
jóvenes africanos no tengan la necesidad
de ir fuera de su continente fuera de
sus países para ir a ver obras que
pertenecen a sus propias culturas esta
ha sido digamos la línea directiva que
él ha tenido y luego él hizo esta
promesa en ese momento habló en
particular de estas obras que hoy van a
ser restituidas a venir pero para esto
se necesitó pasar por un proyecto de ley
que tuvo que ser aprobado por el
parlamento francés y que digamos deroga
el derecho tanto de inalienabilidad
de los son museos nacionales porque aquí
en francia todo aquello que pertenezca a
las colecciones de los museos nacionales
no puede cambiar de propietario sin
importar las condiciones históricas en
las que estas piezas llegaron a los
museos así que hubo que pasar por el
parlamento que aprobó esto hace cerca de
hace un año fue en diciembre del año
pasado y pues hoy finalmente se vio este
momento histórico aquí en parís